ça va être très difficile
merci au festival de cannes à thierry
frémaux à christian jeunes grunt mon
amie ma productrice ma confidente
merci anne dorval nous ont fait
découvrir cette pièce merci max mes amis
ma famille avec qui grâce à dieu je
m'entends beaucoup mieux que mon
protagonistes avec la sienne
merci à tous ceux qui ont fait de ce
film une réalité mes agents les
producteurs les distributeurs les agents
de vente à l'international vous vous
vous connaissez merci au jury
merci d'avoir ressenti l'émotion du film
l'émotion ce n'est pas toujours facile
il n'est pas toujours facile de partager
ses émotions avec avec les autres la
violence sera parfois comme un cri ou
comme un regard qui tue en partant de
matériaux fort qui est juste la fin du
monde du grand jean luc lagarce que
j'espère ne pas avoir rappelé su où
qu'ils soient
j'ai tenté au mieux d'extraire un film
puis de raconter l'histoire et les
émotions de personnages parfois méchant
parfois criard mais surtout blessé et
qui vivent comme tant d'entre nous comme
comme tant de mère deux frères deux
soeurs dans la peur dans le manque de
confiance dans la certitude d'être émis
tout ce qu'on fait dans la vie on le
fait pour être aimé moi en tout cas pris
pour être acceptée
les personnages de lagarce
magnifiquement imaginé par lui et si
humainement jouer incarné par gaspard
ulliel ulliel nathalie baye léa seydoux
vincent cassel marion cotillard n'y
échappe pas plus je grandis plus je
réalise qu'il est difficile d'être
compris et plus paradoxalement je me
comprends moi même et je sais maintenant
qui je suis votre témoignage votre
compréhension et votre amour ce soir mon
ex croire qu'il faut faire des films qui
nous ressemblent avec le coeur à
l'instinct sans compromis sans céder à
la facilité
même si l'émotion est une aventure qui
voyagent parfois mal jusqu aux autres
elle finit toujours par arriver à
destination
elle n'arrivera jamais elle n'arrivera
jamais par contre à mon ami jean
françois barbeau un grand chef costumier
que vous ne connaissez peut-être pas
mais lui
vous connaissez tous et vous suivez tous
un grand chef costumier un grand artiste
qui détesterait d'ailleurs que je le
sais tu piges parle de lui ce soir si
grand et si discret il nous a quittés
sans prévenir et sans avoir vu ce film
je sais qu'il le vue mais je regrette de
ne pas l'entendre en parler gpi s'il ya
deux ans et je vivais un moment
déterminant dans ma vie et en voici un
autre qui changera encore à mon
existence alors la bataille continue
je tomberai des films toute ma vie qui
seront aimés ou non mais comme disait
anatole france
je préfère la folie des passions à la
sagesse de l'indifférence